hello hello everybody
hope you are having a fabulous Friday or
if you're in a time zone that's tomorrow
I hope you're having a wonderful
Saturday
um but it is right and early here in the
United States and we are so excited to
have you here with us on ask doc live
my name is Becca dukes and I will be
your host for the next two hours as we
bring empowering and encouraging
message to you that I hope you will be
able to use if not for just yourself but
for your community because the
information that we share
is something you can do all on your own
you know we go through that stage of do
it yourself well folks when it comes to
our own health who has our best interest
in mind
it's not about a dollar it's not about
any type of underlying motives it's all
about what is best for us so we
encourage you to do it yourself through
food choices and supplementation and on
this program at stock live we are going
to be bringing you information to help
you choose
some of the best options available
because folks you are worth it our
health we need to invest in it and what
we're going to be sharing today helps us
to invest wisely into our own health now
I do have to let you know that if you
are on I don't have to I get to if you
are on this program because you were
invited by somebody special somebody
specific somebody that took the time and
cares about you to share this
information with you make sure that you
get back with them
they took the time and they may even
have a special way of helping you get
the products that are going to be the
best fit for you so if nothing else get
back and thank them for sharing this
information and tell them what you found
the most interesting part of this
program is or was all right now the
content of this program is to provide
educational information on the
importance of nutrition and
supplementation Our Food Supplies around
the world they are void and depleted of
the nutrients they're empty folks
they're empty of the nutrients that our
body needs not just to survive but
Thrive and even if we're on an organic
all-natural
diet and we're watching what we do
you know we don't know what those
Farmers or what those
ranchers are using to feed their animals
and if the minerals are not available
because they do get depleted within the
soils even
it's not going to be in the food so we
need to be intentional in making sure
that our bodies are getting the minerals
that are needed and in this program
we're going to share nutritional options
that provide those minerals and not just
fills the Gap but actually
fortifies
the body and when we think about flower
fortified with this or cereals fortified
with this well folks when you fortify
something it's not about taking this and
this out so that you get that those
cofactors everything that's present the
body needs and that's where we use Whole
Foods for the most part that are
plant-derived in
intentionally grown in an area where the
nutrients are replenished into the soils
that they are grown in and and our
program we have
of an amazing doctor that has done more
research more autopsies taken the data
points and correlated them not just from
the human world but also
the animal world or maybe I got that
backwards not just the animal world but
the human world as well and found that
when there is deficiencies there is also
dis-ease in fact over 600 different
conditions have been found to be linked
to mineral deficiencies and
the doctor that we're working with
he has been very instrumental in not
just finding and acknowledging these
efficiencies but making that specific
minerals are getting added into food
sources including baby formula to help
prevent demise
and
without further Ado I would like to
introduce to you one of the
co-founding fathers rather of the
science of epigenetics now if
epigenetics is a new word for you
there's so many different conditions
that have been tagged as genetic and
people lose hope they think well I've
got that genetic marker I might as well
just give up because there's no way
around it well guess what there is the
science of epigenetics has proven that
the genetic theory of disease
transmission is false
what we put into our bodies what we
surround ourselves the toxins that we
intentionally and void and the nutrients
that we intentionally add to our
lifestyle make a difference on how our
genes are expressed and in this program
we
promote that wholeheartedly because of
the doctrine that we have on with us
today
so to guide us we are honored
honored to have one of the recipients of
the 2011 claw Schwartz commemorative
medal the lifetime achievement on
natural medicine and florantrophy from
the United Nations and in 2015
did I get that wrong doc so 2011 you got
the commemorative medal
you got the lifetime achievement
so everybody
all right we want to introduce to you Dr
Joel Wallach Dr Wallach welcome to ask
doc live uh thank you so very much uh
there we go thank you so very much Becca
and team uh there's a great great
introduction of course
um the epigenetic story is huge
um because it was very obvious after uh
let's see after 10 years and 20 000
autopsies
um
the W.B Saunders published my thesis as
a textbook sold them for twenty five
thousand dollars each so the average
stock put the book down put the book
down oh you're blocking your voice from
the microphone
for you okay you put the book
too
the
um it was very obvious we had to get the
information to the general public so we
came up with the book epigenetics The
Death of the genetic theory of disease
transmission and
um this is just blown all the old
theories away because it's very very
obvious there are no jaguely transmitted
diseases there are no autoimmune
diseases your body doesn't attack itself
um in in the
uh which I see in the old world of
course you can only see my left eye now
I don't know what's going on no I see
you something popped up in front so just
ignore that and just look at the camera
camera smile and talk okay okay
and so happy jack this book now sells
for 25 not 25 000 but 25 everybody can
afford that and uh that's me with one of
the monkeys from the Yorkies Primary
Center at Emory University uh 1977 when
I discovered the first non-human case of
cystic fibrosis thought to be one of the
worst genetically transmitted birth
defects and it was a simple nutritional
efficiency when I proved it to him they
fired me and that's when I went back to
school became a naturopathic physician
so I could treat people and so that's
how that's the starting version of the
story and so with that
I want you to kind of like a little
um base framework which many of you have
heard before
um and I was on the Philippines on a
zoom last night and the life expectancy
the people in the Philippines of 71.
the life expectancy of the USA is 75.
the life expectancy of Australia we're
going to be at tonight on a zoom is 82.9
New Zealand is 82.3 Japan is 84.7 wait a
minute we're only 75. okay Canada's 84.
China's 76. the UK is 81. Russia is 72
South Africa is 63. they're one of the
lowest life expectancies of the
industrialized World Italy's 83.
um let's see here Sweden is 82.7 Egypt
is 71. Germany is 81.26 another funny
one Spain is 82. Ukraine 71.
um Denmark is 70
77.2 the point that I'm getting at here
there's kind of like this sort of range
between 70 and 85
that the industrialized Nation lives in
okay so that's what we're starting out
at as we're starting out at then you
have to look at you know diseases like
arthritis a very simple basic disease
which doctors one should believe are
genetic or autoimmune and so for the
really just a simple nutritional
deficiencies we spend
626.8 billion dollars a year just
treating the symptoms of arthritis
626.8 billion dollars a year in the
United States alone okay osteoporosis
and again a simple nutritional
deficiencies not genetic not autoimmune
each year in America we spend 2.3
trillion in dollars because with a t so
to treat the symptoms of osteoporosis
and arthritis we're spending three
trillion dollars a year in the United
States I wonder why there's so many
orthopedic surgeons
okay type 2 diabetes we have 37.3
million Active cases after diagnosis
probably three times that many who are
not diagnosed by doctors because you can
figure this out you don't need a
prescription to get a test strip from
the pharmacy or or to get a test strips
to check the sugar in your urine and so
forth
and right now
um like I said it's 37.3 million doctor
diagnosed cases of diabetes in America
there's 96 million pre-diabetics in
America 96 million one third of our
population are pre-diabetics say simple
nutritional deficiency disease and we
spend 342 billion dollars to treat the
symptoms I wonder why there's so many
um
doctors who treat diabetes hmm okay
you're getting the picture and I could
go into a whole bunch of others but some
of you heard that before so let's kind
of jump in to the depth of what we're
getting at to today
the life expectancy okay a professional
athletes in America ranges depending on
the sport 53-59
the
um life expectancy when you take the
total average is 56.7 in America
56.7 holy moly okay when you look at
um let's see here
[Music]
um
uh when you look at athletes
professional athletes who are under 25
years of age there's 2 000
um who die each year suddenly
um uh okay and it's not hypertrophy
cardiopathy heart disease it's the same
disease it actually killed kids under
the age of one year of age
um from death syndrome hypertrophic
emergency doctor Mohan and I we went to
hey Long John Province kishan University
in China we did 1 700 autopsy and kids
under the age of 10 is published in
three languages
um English of course
um and and also Mandarin and Cantonese
is a very well published very well read
document and then when it comes to
billionaires in America and billionaires
in America their average life expectancy
66 now the average lifespan of the
average American is 75. billionaires is
66.
and see here emergency room doctors
emergency room doctors are specifically
that specific specialty is a 58.7 okay
you're getting a picture here we're not
really high up on the list when it comes
to life expectancy
now what we've done is put together
something to answer all your questions
on this subject okay there are three CDs
everybody should get these three CDs
holidays are coming up what a great gift
to give somebody because we'll add 25 to
50 Health figures your life the
information of these three CDs will add
25 to 50 helpful years to your life so
get sets of these for the people you
love your pastor your Rabbi
um your boss you know your neighbors
your family okay here are the CDs dead
athletes don't lie just like Dead
Doctors Don't Lie dead athletes don't
lie because you're supposed to be you
know your exercise you're going to be
healthy no exercise without
supplementation is suicide well that's
another of the CD that's CD number two
exercise on supplementation of suicide
holy moly dead athletes don't lie second
CD
um exercise on supplementation of
suicide we go through the basic problem
why people get all these different
diseases
in my exercise accelerates
the progress the negative progress of
these diseases as well as showing up
okay thirdly a great CD one of my
favorites is what kills billionaires
what kills billionaires come on these
people have all the money on the earth
and yet they their life expectancy is 66
and so we went back and looked at all
the information on what diseases are
very specific to billionaires and it
will blow your mind okay and then of
course
now let's see here uh let's uh go to you
can actually go to youngevity official
private uh Facebook group youngevity
official private Facebook group uh and
go to uh right click uh and punch
um save right click and save and you'll
be able to take all that information off
onto your own websites you can order
those three CDs Now that is only for
people that are youngevity Distributors
though doc okay so we have well you got
to be registered to have access to that
okay absolutely but then to go to your
youngin distributor and ask for those
three CDs and they'll get them for you
okay now
here's kind of a clue of what's going on
here let's look at energy drinks let's
look at energy drinks this is one of my
passions of course I was an athlete I
lettered in wrestling and football uh
both in junior high well in high school
and college I was I was very very big On
Athletics I was a strong Farm kid uh
let's see here monster came out in 1985
that was a Coca-Cola product monster the
first commercial energy drink Red Bull
came out in 1987 it's from Austria at
Australia Austria okay and
um then came Rockstar in 2001 from Pepsi
Cola in youngevity we came out with our
energy drinks board shrink in 2011. it
was called rebound
okay rebound okay now let's get to the
bottom line here let's get to the bottom
line okay
let's look at what's in
rebound R is for shrink Red Bull
and Rockstar
let's look at uh salt sodium chloride
um in let's see here
um in Rockstar there's 40 milligrams
in Red Bull there's 140 milligrams
in rebound there's 20 milligrams when it
comes to sugar
Rockstar has 31 grams Red Bull has 38
grams and let's see here rebound has 24
grams now this is one that blew my mind
when we put this together
I'm going to come to minerals which you
know help you deal with energy and and
so forth and maximize health and push
off inflammation and so forth these
minerals Rockstar has one mineral in it
only one mineral Red Bull has three only
three minerals our rebound has 75.
you've heard me say this a thousand
times
rebound contains 75 minerals and 25
vitamins amino acids
and so we have 75 times
70 times 75 times the amount of minerals
that's in Rockstar we have 25 times the
amount of minerals that's in Red Bull
and then let's look at vitamins
we have 12 vitamins and 12 amino acids
so we I always say we have 25 vitamins
amino acids and 75 minerals it's 100
nutrients in our rebound score strength
okay
um Red Bull has four vitamins and
Rockstar has five when it comes to
caffeine 80 milligrams in Rockstar 114
milligrams in Red Bull and in rebound we
get our caffeine from let's see here
um I think it's green cheese yeah Green
Tea Green Tea I'm in the process of
finding out exactly how many milligrams
so probably by next week I'll have the
amount of milligrams of green tea
um caffeine that's in our drink but
anyway just the 75 minerals alone is
enough to take our sport slash energy
drink okay we give you energy all day
I popped the top on two of those cans
every night put them in the refrigerator
so by morning the
uh here we go by morning okay the uh all
the bubbly's gone it's and I like it
right but we we leave the bubbly in
there because so many people like the
carbonation okay this has a hundred
nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
vitamins and amino acids okay I love
this rebound and then of course we have
a six it's the same formula there's 36
in a box
okay 30 sticks in a box
oh there we go got to get the direction
right now right in front of you doc
there you go
there you go okay so turn them around
yeah don't worry about it there we go so
that's that's our powder and individual
sticks making it convenient to go yeah
yeah I'd stick two or three of these in
my pocket so I'm on the road during the
day I can do this I don't carry open
cans with me okay then of course we have
the canister there's 36 servings in the
canister okay 36 servings in the
canister
there we go you got it okay has a little
scoop in there so one scoop one scoop
that's two
two servings and then of course
one of my favorites is
let's see here this is the what oh
hand sanitizer hand sanitizer oh
okay hand sanitizer and this you should
carry with you all the time and get
those little kitchen those little thin
um plastic you know you pull them out of
a box kind of like Kleenex a little
kitchen gloves and so forth they're like
two or three cents each okay get those
when you go out uh wear them and put
some hand sanitizer on the outside okay
and put the hand sanitizer on the
handles of the shopping carts and all
that kind of stuff this is going to save
a lot of people okay the hand sanitizer
so that's just a few over 600 products
while I take that back we have five
thousand plus we do it over 600
different diseases
okay
now let's see what else we have here
um
all right
and then of course we have already told
you about osteoporosis okay we have
um osteoporosis uh we it's terrible the
osteoporosis problem we have in America
okay and we we spend so much time and
money and energy in dealing with
osteoporosis or we're talking about
2.3 trillion dollars we spend to treat
osteoporosis in the USA 2.3 trillion
with a t so you had the
626.8 billion of arthritis which is just
osteoporosis of joints we're talking
about three trillion dollars a year
we're spending just to treat the
symptoms of osteoporosis arthritis
and that's just doctor diagnosed that's
just diagnosed doctors doctors diagnose
numbers okay and again there's 12 pairs
of um fellow pairs of cranial nerves in
the spinal cord one of my favorite ways
to find out how severe the osteoporosis
is in somebody's skull and there's 37
different diseases that are diagnosed
and people get osteoporosis of the skull
37.
and I always ask them how many times you
get up at night to urinate once three
times five times and say oh gosh I get
up five times a night I get up 10 times
a night and like once every hour I'll
have to get up and urinate well that
that's not your prostate gland well
especially if you're a girl because
girls don't have prostate glands okay
what's happening is the skull is
squeezing the spinal cord and the spinal
cord is telling your urinary bladder to
urinate
okay and then of course when the skull
squeezes cranial nerve number one and oh
one of my favorite pictures of my
favorite pictures in the book is on your
head which goes into those oh this is
one of my being a Pathologists one of my
favorite pictures of page six on the
front end
page six uh here we go now you look at
this okay the top one is a normal skull
the top one is a normal skull
yeah there we go I got it DOC you got it
you have to come further part no the
other direction other direction other
keep keep it going keep it going there
you go there you go okay you notice the
top one is a quarter of an inch thick
that's a normal skull the bottom one is
it's called with osteoporosis it's over
an inch thick okay I've seen them two
inches thick and that's okay thank you
dear
we're cool thank you and so this is why
you can understand why they're squeezing
those nerves are coming out through the
skull okay optic nerve atrophy slowly
slowly slowly you're losing your your
Visions I don't know why you're losing
your vision that's because you have on a
optic nerve atrophy because the skull is
squeezing the optic nerve the optic
artery in the optic vein and you get
macular degeneration when you squeeze
the nerve and the artery in the vein you
get macular degeneration it's not a
genetic thing it's not autoimmune thing
and then ptosis the pupil will not
respond to light okay that's a clue
nerve number four being squeezed you get
double vision cranial number five being
sweet I mean we're talking about painful
if you think you've had a headache
before when you get the trigeminal
neuralgia
um that's the fifth cranial nerve being
squeezed by the skull oh my gosh and
Then trailer nerve number six you get
double vision uh when it's being
squeezed you get Bell's Palsy when the
seventh trailer being squeezed one side
of your face will droop we need to get a
picture of that for next next week Becca
of Bell's palsy and then uh tonight it's
ringing in the ears and deafness and
vertigo as cranial nerve number eight
being squeeze cranial nerve number nine
the loss of gag reflex your voice
swallowing
um voice change and so forth uh lost a
sense of taste that's the next trailer
being squeezed the tenth trailer being
squeezed uh gastroparesis I mean we're
talking significant bringing it to your
knees pain your belly and doctor say oh
you must have a gastric Also let's take
your stomach out you get hiccups you get
AFib when the tenth trailer is being
squeezed there's nothing wrong with your
heart but the skull is squeezing the
10th cranial nerve controls the rate and
Rhythm of the heart panel nerve number
11 is squeeze you lose the ability to
lift your arms above your uh skull your
head okay that's the atrophy of the
trapezius uh
nerve number 11 cranial number 12
atrophy of the tongue and taste and
speech so if you have a squeezing of the
12th Trail nerve and the ninth trailer
nerve you cannot communicate with
anybody then there's 17 different
diseases you get when the spinal cord is
being a squeeze comes out of the Freeman
Magnum which is that big hole in the
back of the skull it's been called
wallix fibrosis Wallace fibrosis
squeezing the spinal cord and you get 17
different diseases including sciatica
hammer toes trigger fingers
you get all kinds of stuff going on
um including uh what should I say
um uh irregular heartbeat you get
so many things in your back uh sciatica
um every kind of thing you can think of
okay so get on the 90 essential
nutrients better yet on the 215 the
healthy brain and heart pack get away
from the bad foods and maximize
absorption utilization and you can add
25 to 50 healthful years to your life 25
to 50 Health years your life become one
of our Warriors become one of our
Warriors get on it and make it happen
Okay over to you Becca
all right Dr Wallach and one thing I
want to point out folks as Dr Wallach
was going through these different
diseases that have been linked to
osteoporosis of the skull it's not rare
diseases it's some of the most common
and frequently
diagnoses that are heard about
all around the world and I think
neuropathy is another one of those Dr
will like I know some
you know there there's the diabetic
neuropathy that has to do with blood
sugar and damaging the vessels in the
toes but that squeezing of that vagus
nerve has a lot to do with it as well
so folks I hope you're enjoying the show
so far and the information that is being
shared this program is being brought to
you by askdoc live.com
and if you are here and nobody
specifically invited you or you received
an invitation from our newsletter you
are more than welcome to go to that
website and you will find the
information in regards to the
supplementation that Dr Wallach is
talking about including the 90 essential
nutrients and the healthy body start
pack and the brain and heart pack with
the 215 nutrients which is the biggest
hammer in the box when it comes to the
foundation of supplementation so as Dr
Wallach is going through if you have
questions and you are on live with us
today go ahead and raise that virtual
hand go to reactions in the zoom menu
and there you will find Ray's hand so
that we can call upon you to ask your
question in the order that your hand was
raised we also have the chat open
our amazing co-hosts Roselyn Sanchez
nasima Omar Heather
Bowen
it's pretty sad since she's my sister
um and
Judy Reynolds are here with us today to
make sure that we have all of the
information that you need easy to find
and if I miss something if there's a
question they send me a message so that
I
don't miss it as we're going through the
program today so with that being said
again get with back with the person that
invited you to hear this information and
give them a great big thank you if
you're close enough to give them a hug
give them a hug there's been too many
too many moments lost of being able to
give people hugs and share appreciation
so let's go to the first hand Dr Wallach
and we have Wayne Wayne go ahead and
unmute yourself
good morning good morning good morning
and if you have a camera and would like
to come on camera with us that would be
fabulous but how can we help you today
Wayne uh this question is about diabetes
too
and I studied a lot
through my training and a lot of
Physicians and I want to know how the
doctor differentiates
insulin resistance
without just the body not making enough
insulin
because I never really heard a good way
of deciphering between the two
sometimes I hear you don't have enough
insulin sometimes I hear there's not
enough insulin going into the cells
okay
well you have to appreciate that
um there's uh your pancreas has cells
okay in the eyelids of langerhan that
make insulin and they can make too
little insulin they can make a lot of
insulin they can make too much insulin
uh when they make too little insulin
um you're just they they say oh you're
having a trouble using insulin well
that's because you're only making 10
what you need and so when they stay you
have insulin resistance that usually
means you're not making enough
they're translating it incorrectly
you're not making enough
and then this could be because you're
eating gluten we'd run around oats and
so because you're eating gluten and
you're not absorbing the nutrients are
necessary for the pancreas to make
insulin okay then people get reactive
and hypoglycemia uh you eat a big dinner
you go sit down on the couch after
dinner with everybody else in the family
in a 30 to minutes to an hour later
you're asleep snoring on the couch
everybody else is giggling and laughing
and pointing at you because you fell
asleep on the couch a half hour after
dinner because your your pancreas
released a lot of insulin
and it it dropped your blood sugar down
below 60 down below 50 and you fell
asleep you have reactive hypoglycemia
that's very very common
oh yeah you don't want to eat a big meal
I have to take a nap well that's because
you have reactive hypoglycemia
and then when you have an insulin
deficiency that means that your pancreas
isn't getting the nutrients it needs to
make insulin
all right that's why we have sweeties
that's why we have sweeties you want to
take the the healthy grain and heart
pack as Becca pointed out take the hell
the Grain and hard pack one of those for
100 pounds by the way how much do you
weigh
about 2 30. 231 okay you need two
healthy branded heart facts a month to
follow those everything twice a day then
I want you to get two bottles a month of
our sweeties
take three of those twice a day take
three breakfast three dinner time
and that's going to give you uh enough
of the
um uh active insulin you need if
you're avoiding all the bad foods so it
can absorb it you have to be able to
absorb all this stuff to get the benefit
just putting it in your mouth it was
coming out the other end you're not
getting the benefits so got to stay away
from wheat barley rye and oats there are
no such things that gluten-free oats the
gliadin and oats are still gluten and
then there's also buckwheat buckwheat
has phagopyrins in it which is just as
bad in some cases as worse than uh
gluten the fagotpyrins and it causes
lupus and rheumatoid arthritis all kinds
of stuff so you want to stay away from
buckwheat don't even say the word
buckwheat okay that's very dangerous
doesn't have any gluten in it but it has
Sago pyrams in it which is just as bad
it's kind of like saying oh I only shot
myself in the head god with a 22 why am
I here I didn't shoot myself in the hill
with a 45
well the 22 will still kill you should
shoot yourself in the head same way uh
with phagopyries in buckwheat that will
kill you the same as gluten so you have
to be aware of these things and that's
why we are spouting out about these over
and over and over and some people say
well why are you talking about that
stuff so much wallet well because we
have over 300 million people in America
they go to doctors very little thing is
wrong with them including hangnails and
so we need to educate as many as we can
save as many as we can because there'll
be a lot of them we'll dismiss oh
doctors will say oh there's been nobody
Publishers never been published anything
about osteoporosis goal that's a bunch
of nonsense don't that's you know some
hippie idea okay well they don't teach
how she approaches to the skull
because if you can cure osteoporosis of
the skull with nutrition and diet
why can't you
why can't you treat and cure
osteoporosis of your bones uh in your
arms or your legs and your back your
pelvis
huh remember they bake 2.3 trillion
dollars a year to treat the symptoms of
osteoporosis why would they want to have
you cure it with vitamins and minerals
okay
you said you want to avoid carbonated
beverages yes what's the connection with
that why you avoid it because that does
not help well carbonation or neutralizes
stomach acid
contribution neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals which is
required to absorb minerals you cannot
digest food without stomach acid and so
the good Lord put the chief cells in our
pancreas out it's a langerhans to make
um insulin
okay and so we we need all that stuff
and so you got to stay away from
carbonation carbonation is a fairly
recent thing in the last couple of
hundred years okay and it's one of those
things and well what about all this you
know nationally carbonated water do
people drink they bottle yeah
no sugar but it's carbonated
okay can't have it it's like saying well
I'm going to shoot myself with a copper
jacketable if that's safe because the
lead won't touch me
is that stupid that's stupid okay and so
the the which they say the medical
system knows very little or nothing
about nutrition
you know very little or nothing about
digestion and absorption
they know very little about what
diseases you get
asked a medical doctor how many diseases
are caused by
nutritional deficiencies
ask the doctor your medical doctor honey
diseases are caused by autoimmune things
going on with your body attacks itself
and genetics
you'll start railing off things like
rheumatoid arthritis which is just a
simple nutritional deficiency of your
joints with a secondary problem of
um
an infection with a bug called
mycoplasma which is easily killable
with
um with a antibody called
Minocycline like The Bait fish minnow
you know cycling will kill the bug that
causes rheumatoid arthritis you still
have to take your Healthy Bone and Joint
pack or your health depending on how
many other uh things you got going on
you could take the healthy brain and
heart pack with the extra MSM and so
forth and the collagen peptides
say two to six weeks you can get rid of
rheumatoid arthritis
I'm still not sure how to differentiate
though insulin resistance
from just not
because you're not absorbing the
nutrients required for insulin to work
okay that's the difference
that's the difference
it doesn't matter
50 pounds 50 pounds of insulin a day but
if you're taking stuff to prevent it
from being absorbed or produced that's
meaningless
right
so why are your nutrients being absorbed
more than the standards I get vitamin C
at a big box store or something like
that what makes vitamins more special I
know you don't have much time but well
again we have 75 minerals in our product
how many minerals
are in the product from you know these
other companies
15 12 8 6 possibly yeah not possibly
there's no there's none of them that
have more than 20.
right except us we have 75.
okay now you have to appreciate who has
the longest lifespan in the world the
hunzas
okay
um they have a life expectancy of 120 we
didn't get into that today they have a
life expectancy 120. what makes it tons
is different is genetic snow they live
in these little valleys in the Himalayan
Mountains and they're surrounded by
these
um
volcanoes they're showered 24-7 with
volcanic ash into their water supply
their ponds and rivers and creeks and
lakes as well as into their
agricultural fields
and they're getting all these barrels
they're getting 75 barrels constantly
showering down upon them and that's why
they live to be 120. that's their
expectancy many of them live to be 130
140 150 160 okay and so that's why when
they when they list who lives the
longest and and so forth they're saying
into the industrialized Nation because
that way they can leave out the hunzas
because if they put in the hunzas into
those facts they say well why are they
living to be 120 and we only live to be
um 60. there's something wrong here
must be genetics no
it has to do with access
okay so I hope that answers your
question thanks
thank you Wayne great great questions I
myself was deemed to be insulin
resistant just before the year before
finding the youngevity products and
nothing that I did
um was able to connect that until I got
on the minerals and so Dr well like we
use plan derived colloidal minerals
they're in tiny little particles that
can go through the digestive system and
when you take that gluten out
and take that coating that limits and
prevents and
totally
takes away from the absorption of what
our body needs most
you get even better absorption yeah it's
a very good observation back and of
course when we started youngeity you
know over 50 years ago
um is one of those things where we spent
a long time looking why we want to be
different than everybody else we don't
want to be just another label on the
same
formula and so we looked around the
world and we realized that the hunzas
were the ones that were doing the best
and so what were they doing was the
exact thing or was it what were they
doing well we found out that it was a
volcanic ash and so we have the hold on
five different locations on Earth in
which says volcanic ash
um is
um in in minable quantity minable
quantities and this is where we get our
minerals we don't grind up Limestone to
get calcium or magnesium okay Red Bull
only has magnesium in it we have 75
minerals Red Bull has only magnesium
which one is going to give you more
sustained energy which one is going to
give you more sustained connective
tissue and and cartilage and ligaments
and tendons and Bone's health is going
to be Red Bull with magnesium are are
healthy brain and heart pack with 75
minerals on it
75 versus one hello Okay so this we
spent six months traveling around and
finding out and getting analyzes from
universities all over the world before
we decided what we were going to do and
that's why we're different this is not
just another me too product this is not
just another me too company we are
totally different we are totally
different from any other nutritional
company on Earth
so that's a great question
yes absolutely a lot of research went
into this before even thinking about
coming up with a solution to what Dr
Wallach found to be the underlying cause
of so many different diseases
so let's go to the next town that's up
but before we do Dr Wallach there's
something that I wanted to to bring up
something that I appreciate is you often
say that minerals are like chocolate
swirl ice cream where the there's veins
of minerals and the fact that there are
five different
sources throughout the country or
throughout the world that our minerals
are taking from
just gives us more variety and more
opportunity to get all of those
nutrients so that I greatly appreciate
and I think others do as well
let's go so you know they're in the
ocean underneath coral reefs they've
been there for millions of years okay
and so we get them from all over the
place we get them from Mountain sources
um we we get them from um
coral reefs in the ocean if we get them
from everywhere we're not just grinding
up the local rocks
that's right because our bodies
I don't know about you Dr Wallach but if
I tried to dissolve Rock and water
and then I I think about okay if it's
not going to absorb in water and I put
it in my system how is it going to
absorb into my system efficiently
not gonna do it it's not it's just not
and then back to the carbonation so I
found that
1740 somewhere between 1740 and 1767
is when carbonation was first discovered
and was started to be implemented into
liquid sources so yeah there's such a
unique thing that this is what they
started using in the bars in the taverns
and stuff was you know a carbonated
water
carbonated drinks that's where they
started you know before they put it in
cans and things
yeah so all right let's go to the next
tan Dr wellick and we have Susan Susan
go ahead and unmute yourself
and before you say anything Susan
um if you are on live with us please
make sure that you have your first name
and initial or initial and a last name
up we want to make sure that everybody
that's on with us is a real legitimate
person
um and also if you decide to have your
camera on please make sure that
everything is decent in your area and
there's not a lot of distractions we
want to make sure that we are focused on
the content of this program and not have
to worry about there being any type of
interference or anything pulling away
from the knowledge that's being shared
today so Susan
I'm fantastic thank you I'm visiting a
friend in Costa Rica and having a
wonderful time and I want to say how
much I appreciate your product so
they've done some wonders for me at 78
I'm healthy and Hearty and having a
great time and I wanted to um tell you
I'm a distributor and a friend of mine
said her doctor told her not to do salt
she's diabetic
um I don't have much other information
about her but I want you to know if you
could talk about salt why would her
doctor tell her not to take salt or to
take very very little and what is that
doing to her body if she doesn't take
salt and if she should take it what
should she take
you ever heard the term oh he's a
wonderful guy he's the salt of the earth
yeah so why does people say that
hundreds of years ago
well that's because salt was one of the
greatest
what should I say things that ever
happened to humanity
sodium chloride
um was the first
nutritional supplement sold in the world
salt
people along the coast who live longer
than people on the Inland they would
take sea water and boil it and down to
Salt but it not only had the sodium
chloride but it also had the other
minerals that were in the salt water and
they would go Inland 50 or 100 or 200
miles or a thousand miles and sell it
for a lot of money
okay seesaw and people's thyroid
problems would go away in a couple weeks
they'd had thyroid issues for years and
they'd take the sea salt
and because it had iodine in it in two
weeks six weeks the glider would go away
and all the local Witch Doctors
all that kind of stuff couldn't get rid
of the lighter but they did with the sea
salt
has two essential nutrients
okay out of the 90. sodium and chloride
they're stared by themselves essential
nutrients
and so when a doctor says oh
um you got to get rid of salt
then the first thing you should do is
say you're fired get up put your clothes
on Mark just stop out stop make a lot of
noise leave it you're fired and say that
in the waiting room full of people
you're fired okay because they're
telling you go kill yourself or go
create a disease in yourself because I
have kids in college and tuitions do
do not listen to a doctor when they say
you have to stop using salt it's like
saying don't use oxygen you're going to
rust
so I hope that answers your question
um can you talk about it in terms of
digestion
digestion oh yeah well sodium chloride
what is stomach acid it's hydrochloric
acid
so how do you make hydrochloric acid for
digestion you need sodium chloride salt
okay so salt is involved in just about
everything going on in your body every
cell in your body requires salt every
organ in your body requires salt every
system in your body requires salt
the only people who don't like salt or
doctors
so say I'm sorry doc but I'm out of here
just grab I don't even get dressed just
grab all your clothes under your arm and
March stomp out through the waiting room
your fire you're fired
and people chase out there wow what's
going on
that idiot told me to give up salt
it's like saying don't breathe anymore
because you have asthma you don't want
oxygen don't breathe anymore that'd be
stupid
but that's the same thing as don't use
salt
thank you thank you Dr Wallach I
appreciate you very much thank you thank
you great question
okay so Dr Wallach I have a question
um that came up in regards to that so if
somebody has taken a healthy body brain
and heart pack
appropriate for their weight do they
need enough or do they get enough salt
from that or they don't need to Salt
their Foods
well
um unless you're getting dehydrated I
would still salt my food in fact I do
you know we are traveling together a lot
and you see me salt my food constantly
that's why we have our Himalayan salt
which is the salt from the Himalayan
Mountains it or these be oceans many
millions of years ago and the oceans
went away and so all the salt and all
the minerals and the Sea came down and
they also have all these volcanoes
and so the Himalayan
um sea salt has a sodium chloride but it
also has 28 different minerals
because the location location then we
also have the
um let's see here it is assault from
um the season salt from Australia thank
you yeah the season itself from
Australia okay and you'll notice
that
it's either from a current ocean like it
is from Australia and New Zealand
okay are an ancient ocean like it is in
the Himalayas okay and this is something
where I never fail whether it's
breakfast lunch or dinner
breakfast lunch and dinner and from just
having a snacky lunch I would still put
that either the season
um sea salt on from Australia New
Zealand or the Himalayan salt okay I I
never failed to take my salt
because every cell in your body requires
salt to function your digestion requires
salt for stomach acid
okay you require salt for cooling when
you exercise or you're working hard and
sweating you need salt
every cellular body requires salt to
keep this hydrostatic pressure correctly
so they don't dehydrate or rupture all
that kind of stuff so anybody who says
don't sell all your food there'll be
plenty of natural in your food
um no sorry
saw your food and say where do you want
to tell people who tell you those kind
of stuff is uh would you write down
where you want to be buried because if
you're following what you're telling me
to do you're not belong for this world
you're going to die so I want to make
sure you get buried where you want to be
buried
you're so thoughtful Dr wellick but
let's keep this let's keep this positive
and hope and because we're sharing
information that is going to be
beneficial when implemented not just
hearing it but actually using the
information
in regards to
creating a health Journey that
is more favorable
I know my son gives me a hard time about
salting my food my oldest son he's like
Mom you're always using salt and like
Yeah and I don't have digestive issues
like somebody else I know that's
well he's not half my age anymore but
you know
a few years younger
so and he's like okay touche touche
so
salt your food folks it's gonna help
create those digestive juices that the
body needs to be able to break down the
food so it doesn't just sit in your
stomach and ferment and cause havoc on
the digestive system and it keeps your
cells hydrated in your body because
without salt your cells are dehydrated
and you become a mummy not a mommy but a
mummy
that's right
all right well let's go to the next town
that is up Dr Wallach and Alma Alma go
ahead and unmute yourself you're on live
with Dr Wallach
hi good morning
my name is Alma so um I'm having a
situation I've been dealing with five
roads for quite some years
um the doctor just said just leave them
alone and if it gives you a problem down
the future we'll look into it so now
they're grown to a point where they're
causing me anemia and um other health
issues I guess okay okay stop are you
bleeding are you bleeding from yeah I'm
um during my periods I bleed a lot okay
so heavy fairy periods um and it gets
heavier and heavier and longer days as
well
um and now it's causing me anemia which
caused me to get iron infusions already
okay and how much do you weigh and how
old are you I'm 40 years old and I
weighed 135. okay how tall are you
I'm five feet
five feet yeah okay yeah so you know if
five feet you might be maybe 20 pounds
over a week kind of thing a little bit
not much but a little bit okay any other
issues any low blood sugar do you have
any diabetes you have Howard pressure do
you have any arthritis do you have
thyroid issues
no I don't have any of that okay do you
have any white gray or silver hair
yeah I have a few gray hairs
okay
all right and so
um what I would do is go ahead and take
uh one healthy brain and heart pack a
month take a half of those everything
twice a day I would also get the
let's see here uh none of the bad foods
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no glutens no wheat around oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbonated drinks
and then one healthy branded heart pack
per month they half a dose of everything
twice a day uh one bottle of MSM so you
take three breakfasts three at dinner
time I would also have you take the
collagen peptides for the connective
tissue in the uterus and go ahead and
take one scoop of your morning drink one
scoop of the evening drink that's two
canisters per month I go ahead and take
the
seraphim
x-e-r-a-f-e-m seraphim it's the raw
materials that your ovaries need to make
estrogen and progesterone and that kind
of stuff okay I won't see three eggs
twice today with soft yolks oh she
cholesterol three eggs twice a day with
soft yolks hard-boiled eggs won't count
fried eggs will cause cancer so you need
um the let's see here uh soft boiled
soft coat soft soft scrambled and butter
not margarine or Oils okay give your
body the raw materials it needs because
95 of the weight of 95 of the weight of
estrogen in females and testosterone in
males is cholesterol
if you want hormones you've got to eat
those eggs when your doctor says no no
cholesterol give up eggs I'm going to
put you on a Statin drug to lower your
cholesterol your cholesterol is too high
change your doctors because your doctor
doesn't know what he or she is talking
about
okay
okay call us every couple of weeks let
us know how it's going because you're
going to see Improvement two weeks and
four weeks and six weeks and we want to
see what's going on there okay okay I
can ask you another question I'm so
sorry
um do this has anything to do with my
stomach being bloated like I've been
feeling lately at night that when I eat
even if I eat small amounts of food my
stomach gets very bloated at night I
don't know why well do you salt your
food
um yes I do
do you salt it with our salt with all
the trace minerals in it
yeah I think I bought some Himalaya salt
okay
are you eating gluten do you eat um what
do you eat for breakfast so I actually
stopped I used to do oatmeal every day
for many many years uh or add it to my
shape
yeah I stopped it already when
um I stopped it maybe about a month ago
or okay yeah but it would take you six
months to heal your intestines to be
able to efficiently absorb all this
stuff okay you've been eating oatmeal
all your life that's why you have all
these problems your gray hair when
you're gray hair starts coming back in
its natural color whether it's blonde or
red or brown or black your hair color
will come back and uh people are saying
oh you look 25 years younger what are
you doing that's because your hair color
is coming back because you're now
absorbing the nutrition necessary for
your hair color to be
um
engineered if you want to you can throw
in the um I've seen here the Hair Skin
and Nails take three of those twice a
day that will speed up the recovery
because you'll see the hair color coming
back when the hair color comes back that
means all these nutrients are getting to
your cells but yeah if you've been
eating oatmeal all your life that's the
reason why you've had trouble but get
off of oatmeal a month ago it's going to
take a couple more months and all your
troubles including the wrong doctors
will go away awesome yeah I actually had
to schedule a surgery already to get
those fibroids out but I'm too afraid
for surgeries yes I I wouldn't go to
surgery especially since you've been on
oatmeal all your life until a month ago
you're at high risk of surgery
oh okay so Dr Wallach did you share with
Alma the the protocol that you would
give her
um
to address the fibroids
I did
all right
well you must have been looking the
other way because I said okay one Health
brain and heart fact okay uh per month I
said the MSM uh the because there's
fibrous connective tissue involved in
the muscles in the uterus right and also
she needs the um uh let's see here the
90 essential nutrients oh yeah that's
the ultimate daily plastic tablets
okay for blood flow she needs of
seraphim the seraphim she's Eggs three
eggs twice a day soft scrambled in
butter soft poached soft boiled no fried
eggs no hard-boiled eggs to get the
cholesterol to make the estrogen
okay okay thank you so much I really
appreciate it okay call us every couple
of weeks because you're gonna have a
great story
a lot of women from unnecessary misery
amen yes
thank you
all right thank you Alma so there was a
question that came up in regards to Salt
doctor while I can is rocks the rock
salt sufficient
um and how is it different than just a
regular salt
okay well regulars while you buy you
know off the counter in a grocery store
is salt sodium chloride sometimes you'll
add item it'll say iodized salt will add
iodine to it so it has salt sodium
chloride in one mineral iodine
okay our seasoned salt and our Himalayan
salt
has a sodium chloride
plus when you take it all with all our
other stuff it has 75 minerals in it in
addition to the Salt
is 75 minerals more valuable than one if
you're just getting iodized salt
well I'm gonna say coming from a
statistician point you don't have to be
a statistician to figure that one out
yeah it's like would you just put dirt
from Texas in your car instead of oil
saying save a few bucks
not even in my Jeep not even your worst
nightmares would you do that okay
and so
um and so that's what you're doing well
I'm just gonna eat my doctor said I can
just eat well and get everything I need
you need to change doctors immediately I
wouldn't even pay him the last bill he
sends you okay so if you send me another
bill I'm going to go to the Medical
Association
okay
um this is because they give you a lot
of misinformation because they know if
they tell you all the correct stuff
you won't need them anymore
hello
well you're kind of mean Wallick there's
some good doctors out there well it's
true
you know what percentage
of doctors are 100 for the patient
uh two percent five percent ten percent
25 I don't know
I think that's gonna be my next project
I'm gonna find out I'm going to send
around
a question here and we'll find out the
answer to that question
well right now Dr Wallach let's go ahead
and take a break before you start on
that journey and folks you are listening
to our stock live here provided by
astocklive.com
my name is Becca dukes and I love the
fact that I have the opportunity and
honor and privilege to bring this
program to you each and every week here
on Zoom where we can go around the world
and then we have our replays that are
available on our website
askdoclive.com and also ksco no no no no
no
kseo is one of our sponsors but
criticalhealthnews.com and for those of
you who are part of our critical Health
news list uh subscriber base welcome we
are so glad that you decided to join us
here today
we will be right back after this short
break again if you have questions for Dr
Wallach go ahead and raise your hand I
love seeing all the hands and if you're
able to turn your camera on Dr Wallach
likes to be able to see the person that
he is speaking with so go ahead and get
ready to turn your camera on as well we
will be right back after this break
all right welcome back everybody to
askdoc live again get with the person
that shared this program with you and
thank them for allowing you to be able
to get information that they're not
hearing from their doctors where there
are a lot of great doctors out there I
have many friends that are doctors
but in school they didn't have much if
any training on the importance of
nutrition and let's just think about it
our bodies what are they created of
in order to support the body to not just
survive but actually thrive
don't we need to continue to give the
body what it was what it's made up of
and that has to do with nutrients
vitamins minerals and Dr Wallach has
done almost 30 000 or just over 30 000
autopsies
on animals and humans
and has discovered all of the different
things that the body's made up of or he
has come to the regulation of all the
things that the body is made up of I'm
sure somebody else did it as well before
him
but then
coincide with okay this disease this
condition
was going on and these deficiencies were
present
so you correct those deficiencies and
what happened
the different diseases
were corrected as well so I love the
fact that we are able to bring him to
you each and every week
sharing this information
because I know I didn't hear it
whenever I was going to the doctors
three four times a week because
I was so sick and miserable
how about you
so I know we have a lot of amazing
people on with us today and let's see if
Dr Wallach is back yet
you have returned there you are
fantastic awesome
well Dr Wallach without hesitation I
mean we have so many hands up let's just
go to the next hand that is up let's do
it and I have Mike Mike go ahead and
unmute yourself
okay
hi Dr Warren yes sir I'm going to help
you I'm trying to
start the video
I spoke to you a couple of months ago my
mother-in-law she's in a coma she's uh
of course female 86 years old about five
foot tall she's about 95 pounds
uh she's been in a coma for about three
months uh how she's right now in ICU uh
she can react to people to talk to her
however she does not uh she can't talk
or she can't she can try to Blink her
eye a bit
and I want to know she's got bit sauce
can I what can we applied for her bit
sauce you know and also she's being fed
through the tube uh can we give a
vitamins and minerals in liquid form
through the tubes
well you can but it'll be very
interesting to see if the doctors will
let you do that
okay so here's the deal let me tell you
a story okay this is a story time
about 10 years ago
I was called by one of our great
Distributors up in New England okay in
Maryland Linda Linda Tyler
and um she is a very faithful person
and her Pastor Mike Freeman was in a
coma for six months in the hospital
okay
he's in a coma for six months Pastor
Mike Freeman the doctors told everybody
look he's only got days to live maybe
minutes so if you want to say goodbye to
him and maybe he can hear you you need
to come in now
so she calls me and says there's
anything we can do for him he doesn't
have a G-tube so he can't give him
anything early
they took his IV out
because you know he's been getting worse
and worse and worse worse I think
they've tried work so the end is here
anything we can do for him
so yeah we just take our plant derived
colloidal medals this you know this
bottle of our plants arrive collateral
metals
and put a half a teacup of that on his
chest with some cotton balls they're on
his belly with some cotton balls then if
you can sort of sort of lift him up on
his side and put um a half a teacup on
his his back between his shoulder blades
and his lower back
do that three times a day
she said she'll do it
so she is Pastor Mike's wife did that
by the third day she calls me she's all
excited she says
Pastor Mike got up this morning
he shaved went back to work at the
church he was sat down in the studio in
the TV studio in the radio studio and
told his story we have and you need to
get this set and make sure the doctor
listens to it
well you may have to take him out to
dinner to have him listen to the whole
thing and look at the things it's a set
it's a CD and a DVD because Pastor Mike
when he recovered
he put all this onto this set and we
named it praise the Lord and pass a 90.
praise the Lord and pass in 90. we don't
sell as many that said as we should we
should be selling a thousand of those
sets a minute okay
praise the Lord and pass to 90.
and you see the pictures of him
three days after he woke up from a
six-month coma
okay and it's ten years later and he's
still kicking butt
okay
he's one of the biggest outgoing most
proactive uh pastors for our product of
any on Earth Pastor Mike Freeman
Baltimore Maryland okay so that's the
story praise the Lord and pass the 90.
praise the Lord and pass the 90 praise
the Lord and pass the night so I hope
you get it
yes sir
what can you put on the bed sores
because his mother-in-law has bed sores
well uh on the bed sores
um
gosh I would just go ahead I would go
ahead and put the um
uh
the colloidal silver
yeah there you go put the colloidal
silver on there and shows there's an
infection or the colloidal silver will
kill the bug
okay
okay okay so basically the plane derived
colloidal minerals that's what I should
apply on the
yeah on her chest and her belly her back
between her shoulder blades her lower
back three times a day a half a cup each
time so it'll be a cup and a half for
the plant derived minerals
and then the colloidal silver on the Bed
store there's no alcohol in it so it
won't burn it won't burn or sting
but if let's say she gets uh back home I
mean that's what uh okay
excuse me I said let's go get her back
home keep doing the same thing
yeah no no what I mean is that can we
put the uh like a liquid um minerals and
vitamins in her cubes for feeding it no
not IV no her oral tubes not an IV tube
not not the IV tube but the feeding tube
yes she used to feed her the
um
um let's see here I'd go ahead and feed
her the ultimate let's see here excuse
me
um the BTT 2.0
essentially you're going to give her
through that feeding tube
um
so basically I mean uh like the BTT the
established as well as they said no no
no no no no no tablets are not nutrition
for the liquid
so there's a liquid form as well for the
BTT
you have to mix it into liquid yeah yeah
that's what I thought all right I'll do
that thank you sir I appreciate it call
us every two weeks because you're gonna
have a great story
much appreciated bless you uh doctor
thanks Rebecca
you're welcome Mike
all right you definitely keep us up to
date on how she is doing and one thing
that I like to do Dr Wallach because
sometimes when you pour it on the skin
it just kind of rolls off
I like to use a spray bottle and I'll
put the plant dry minerals in the spray
bottle not diluted because they're
already in liquid form and just use that
spray bottle to mist all over the bottom
body let it absorb in a little bit Mist
again and just not have any waste
whatsoever you doing it that way so
that's the way that I like to do it and
I do the same
so I do the same with the colloidal
silver also because that comes in a
dropper bottle where you squeeze it up
and then you can put it on the tongue
and that's great but when it comes to
like putting on a wound
I reuse
our bottle that we have for the ultimate
niacin
I fill it up with the colloidal silver
or the plant derived minerals and then I
can just spray spray
um and then of course label them
that's very important make sure you
label with what's absolutely inside
and take it anywhere
so pretty simple
even on your big toe
I'm sorry you should take it anywhere I
said even on the big toe
that's right
let's go to our next town that is up Dr
Wallach at David
go ahead and unmute yourself one in
California
on live no
thank you
hi Dr Wallace where are you from David
I'm from Connecticut oh Connecticut okay
youngevity products for three weeks now
for my uh pretty bad arthritis in my
back and I've had some great results so
far but that's good my question is from
my wife
um she's had scoliosis for quite some
time and I was wondering if there's
anything any longevity products that
might help her sure how much does she
weigh
she weighs about 100 pounds okay does
she have any other issues thyroid and
heart high blood pressure diabetes
she had a heart and stroke um and she
was 45 she's 60 now she has stents in
her
um hasn't had any problems with that
since
okay so what I would do is get up all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils or glutens no
wheat buttermilanos no sugar no
carbonated drinks no buckwheat and then
I give her one healthy branded heart per
month the half of those everything twice
a day I'd get her on the MSM one bottle
a month so you take three breakfast
three dinner time I'd get her a scoop of
our collagen peptides in our morning
drink and evening drink that's two
canisters per month because they're
small canisters and then I would also uh
let's see here uh let's see here
I would give her the
um
the synaptic Dr Warwick did you mention
the synaptic I didn't I did not mention
the synaptic she could take three of the
synaptic twice a day there's two bottles
a month she's three eggs twice a day
three eggs twice a day so you get the
cholesterol for her brain and spinal
cord and all that to work okay and then
what I was looking for she needs the uh
an inversion table
so she can hang upside down two or three
times a day okay and this is kind of a
gradual thing it might take her a week
or two to be able to get to where she's
able to hang vertical for say 10-15
minutes
um do that two three times a day and
that's going to without surgery a lot of
expense for tools and everything I get
her that um
inversion table and if you're doing the
youngin business as a business you can
buy that inversion table with your
youngevity money
and um
something going on in the world you can
um Also let's see here with the
inversion table you can deduct that off
your taxes because you're going to use
that for your other patients
if you're you know if you're doing this
as a business yes okay
there you go
um thank you very much
yeah do you know get back to us because
people want to know people want to hear
how that worked for her okay
yeah and she's already been um changed
to Lifestyle of eating along with myself
so okay good excellent yeah it's amazing
um and again you have to appreciate that
back in the 1700s the life expectancy
for Americans
was
28 to 35.
the life expectancy for Americans was 28
to 35. in the 1700s
okay and now
you know if you're a billionaire at 66
if you're the average American at 75
so you kind of doubled or tripled the
life expectancy since the 1700s
but we haven't progressed much
as a country or culture
um since I would say uh the 20th century
beginning of the 20th century okay
so farther we can go to like the
hundreds 120.
was the scoliosis from a mineral
deficiency yes
that's where she needs that MSM
um but she only weighs 100 pounds so I
started with one bottle of MSM have her
take three of those fights a day the
collagen peptides are scuba that the
morning breakfast scuba eating breakfast
that's going to help her rebuild her
disc between the vertebrae her tendon
and leave them some connective tissue
and by going and hanging upside down for
10 15 minutes three times a day the body
weight is going to do all the mechanical
stuff that's necessary to slowly rebuild
the discs the tendons and ligaments so
that she'll be able to stand up straight
thank you so much you bet
all right thank you David now Dr Wallach
let's go over to Tammy
um because Tammy has a question in
regards to a six-month-old baby
so Tammy go ahead and unmute yourself
okay I think I did hi there hi what's up
so my best friend's grandson last week
started having seizures
about six months right around six months
old so I'm guessing around 20 pounds
um and he had one and then he had
another and then he must have had one
that was more serious and they actually
flew in from Maui to Oahu to get to a
bigger hospital and they're doing the
genetic testing on them and stuff and I
was just really curious what your
thoughts are and what you would
recommend
I always find it interesting that
doctors want to do genetic testing for a
nutritional deficiency I find that
amazing yeah okay I was a mother
breastfeeding the baby
my suspicion is no the other thing that
was of Interest as far as I know they're
healthy but I do know that the mother
um had as a kid and I'm assuming still
doesn't tolerate Dairy
but I'm thinking that she's probably
formula fed I don't think she I don't
remember I didn't see anything about her
breastfeeding so I think she's probably
formula fed okay so we have kids toddy
it's our baby formula okay so at least
one meal a day yes this baby needs kids
toddy just follows wait don't keep
singing on the back label okay then she
also needs efas and he thinks one EFA at
morning with the other
um drink okay and one EFA plus with our
kid Saudi
she also needs the same how would you
get the efaction it and squeeze it into
the liquid okay okay because it's a soft
shell capsule right right right squeeze
it in Will It mix in with the liquid or
okay okay I haven't actually tried that
okay
and then let's see here oh also the
Cherry mens use the same dosage as you
do for the kids toddy you know like if
if it's um uh right a couple ounces then
right a couple ounces I would use a
couple ounces of the Cherry mens but
okay the Cherry man so I'll use
something like maybe
a half a teaspoon or something yeah okay
and then call US let us know when you
get more details and so forth but this
is a way to start you got to get the
kids tidy the EFA pluses and the and the
Cherry mens into that baby ASAP
so really I think it's just the basic
it's not like some other mineral it's
just really just I went about and
calcium
calcium it's in there it's in the kids
hottie oh the kids taught he has calcium
in it okay it has Complete Nutrition got
it okay good to know I didn't remember
we came up with that we came up with
that when they shut down the
manufacturer of infant formulas in the
United States and they had to go out as
out of the country and they weren't
putting everything in there right now
you have to remember before I forced
them into court in federal court we beat
the FDA in federal court
um nine times including putting
um selenium the traditional selenium
into baby formulas and we ended physio
brosis supposed to be a genetic disease
we ended musculars supposed to be a
genetic disease we ended sediment death
syndrome supposed to be mothers laying
on the baby did you hear that that they
were blaming the mothers and laying on
their babies and suffocating for
Southern Middle syndrome yeah
how dumb are these people okay
I mean it's what they were trained you
know and they don't have the time to do
the research that you've done how dumb
are their trainers yeah well no they're
not done they know where they're making
money oh well there you go thank you
okay thank you so much I do appreciate
the opportunity to talk to you and I
really appreciate all your information
on the products you've given us okay God
bless you dear thank you
okay back to you Becca
thank you Tammy and Dr Wallach let's
just move right along to Cynthia with
her hand up Cynthia go ahead and unmute
yourself if you are able to come on
camera with us that would be fabulous as
well thank you Becca thank you good
morning Dr wallet uh my question is Doc
what how do you help someone I have a
young lady who she has had hysterectomy
and she's still having a lot of hot
flashes
how do you help her
uh let's see here how much does she
weigh do you know she's two 180 and
she's five feet one
okay so she's overweight yes even hot
flashes
and does she have anything like
arthritis or have a pressure diabetes
you know
not to my knowledge doc I know she has
some I think some thyroid issue okay now
are you from Africa or Australia where
are you from I am from the beautiful
island of Jamaica Jamaica oh my gosh
okay okay very good thank you thank you
okay you should
okay I'm coming too all right please
come on down
180 pounds
um she needs to get off all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meat
no oils or gluten so we brought around
so sugar no carbonated drinks
um needs to get
let's see here uh on
uh one no two excuse me two held the
brain and heart pasture months two
Health abandoned hard craps a month the
photos are saying twice a day I want her
to also have three eggs twice a day I
was soft yolk soft wild soft yolks soft
post soft yoke soft soft scrambled and
butter okay out for the cholesterol I
don't want her to make the hormones
which are 95 percent
um cholesterol she also needs a seraphim
xerofem should go ahead and take three
of those twice a day it'll be two Bells
a month and um
let's see here even though she has had
the hysterectomy the zero Femme would
still work for her oh yeah absolutely
because your pituitary gland uh your
adrenal glands make a lot of hormones
and so
um it's not just the ovaries we're
making estrogen
okay okay
thank you so much and you know contact
us let us know how this lady is doing
would you certainly will doc thank you
so much thank you okay thank you so much
Becca looking forward to see you doing
in Jamaica
all right Cynthia I'm all over that trip
okay
well let's go to Yvonne Dr Wallach
Yvonne go ahead and unmute yourself
I know you had a great question in the
chat so I'm glad you came on to present
it
Yvonne the question is
can you unmute yourself my dear
I'm trying there you go
can you see me yes okay excellent
um so doc I've got a client who two
years ago
um fell off her balcony two stories head
trauma
uh she is told that um
she has
uh
s-i-a-h-d theoretic
um
syndrome where her hormones are not
making enough or there's too much in the
bloodstream too much water in the
bloodstream
and it's triggering Central hypoatremia
um and so for two years she's been okay
stop stop hypo what
um atreamia a-t-r-e-m-i-a
okay I've never heard of it what is
hypoatremia well as I understand it the
information is very confusing
um but there's too much water in the
blood
and so if they take in too much fluid
they
um during the old days in the old days
they used to call that anemia
well this is an antideretic hormone
that's you know the the hypothalamus and
the pituitary are secreting
and so she's been living on about a half
a cup of fluid for almost two years
is there any way to help balance this
out it's about the disruption of the
normal uh neuroendocrine system function
yes yes okay you ready you say she
weighs a what's she weigh uh she weighs
about
140 and she is five six okay so what I
want her to do
is take two healthy branded heart packs
a month get rid of all the bad foods no
fried food no processed meat no oils or
gluten no whip our brown nose so sugar
no carbon or drinks I only have two
Heather branded heart packs a month the
fullest thing twice a day she needs two
bottles of the MSM so you can take three
of breakfast three at lunch for dinner
time
and
um then I want her to take
two doses a day
of our
okay
right rebound FX you got it the powder
not the can
I want to take the powder there's no
carbonation in the in the in the powder
in the in the can okay
if she's moving around that would take a
canister with her we do have
the sticks
okay
so this will help her hydrate this will
get all these nutrients into her
um by hydration
and so that's kind of where we'd go and
uh you know get me
um some lab work because I can't believe
that somebody can live on just one cup
of water a day exactly yeah I'm a little
confused so for her to take that I can't
get her to take much of anything she's
so fearful well she needs these
nutrients again
um she can have
a minimum of two doses a day
of the rebound powder she can take three
doses a day if she wants
I only 142 and I take two doses I
actually take more than two doses a day
because they do take the the cans but I
take the carbonation out of the cans but
uh I'll take the cans uh during the day
and then I have the rebound
um also in the powder and the sticks and
so forth plus I have the the nutrients
in my
um drink in the morning in my drink in
the in the evening so I'm just getting
it constantly I'd probably take in uh
with my green tea and everything else I
probably take in
two or three quarts of liquid a day
okay and so somebody just survive on one
cup a day of liquid no there's something
wrong there
yeah and they're telling her she's
taking sodium pills
um you know I think it's LASIK
and but yeah I'll get you some Labs
thank you very much okay thank you
so just something that I want to add Dr
Wallach and that's hypo and this uh
the low concentration of sodium in the
blood
so well then you need more sodium take
our so Becca there's actually uh
different information out there uh I
think I sent something in the chat so
one of them says it's actually too much
water
um but either way she gets extremely
bloated
um you know literally around the feet
Etc and I believe that there's probably
other that's not bloating that's not
bloating that's edema correct I
apologize
yes yeah
um
and but I believe it's probably a
combination of you know various symptoms
but this is what she's being told so I'm
gonna get some some of those labs and
see if yeah it wouldn't hurt to get a
hair analysis on her she could have a
liver disease
okay she could have a liver disease
causing all this
um it wouldn't hurt to take that lab
information to another doctor at the
other end of town that doesn't play golf
or the one that's making this diagnosis
yeah it's interesting you say that um
there's actually a Facebook group with a
bunch of these folks in there so this is
you know growing
condition apparently
so some things Dr Wallach that I found
and I think it might relate to this is
when the body is deficient it's going to
hold on to anything and everything that
it can get
when it doesn't have enough
so like with the edema if it's not
getting enough liquid it's going to hold
on to anything and everything it gets
and that's going to be less as far as
elimination with the natural body
function and it could be liver disease
it could be liver disease it could be
kidney disease it could be heart disease
I mean there's all kinds of stuff could
can cause this see they're talking about
a symptom as plastic medical doctors
right you're talking about the symptom
they're not getting to the basic root
cause of the problem they're treating
the symptom and that's why it's getting
worse because they're treating the
symptom they're not treating the disease
and with that low water her lymphatic is
going to have trouble moving things out
period well not only that you're talking
about blood clots and dehydration right
all kinds of stuff yep wow well I think
she's in good hands with you Yvonne so
we can get the ears to here
well and I appreciate that I have to
help thank you Becca and all of your
team and uh Colonel thank you so very
much I appreciate talking with you
regularly thank you
all right thank you Yvonne lots of
learning moments here today Dr Wallach I
love it yeah it's a beautiful time when
you learn something
so Kathy has a question that she put in
the chat she says will popcorn hurt your
intestines
popcorn hurts your intestines well it
depends
um
how how much you chew it
if you swallow popcorn whole it might
scrape your intestines and cause
scratching injuries if you chew it down
to liquefaction then it won't
there's no gluten
there's no gluten in popcorn
and so you got to watch those little you
know those little golden things in there
that break off and the whole the whole
yeah the little that little round thing
that's golden in color and sharp that's
fine so you gotta chew the popcorn very
well
you want to chew it very well but you
also want to be very intentional on how
you pop it we do not want microwaved
popcorn folks
and Dr Wallach is going to tell us why
this is one of the first stories that I
heard
from Dr Wallach
on microwave popcorn
well you turn the corn oil
into
um very very deadly cancer-causing
um things okay you do not want to be
microwaving popcorn it's very very bad
plus the stuff that they put inside that
bag the oils the artificial flavors all
of those things
they're toxic to the body
so and her next question is
what about the seeds that are baked into
gluten-free bread
and I'm wondering if maybe her questions
are coming from
kind of a slant of
diverticulitis
people who have this condition have a
hard time processing like the whole or
the seeds if they don't get chewed up
enough they get caught in little
Pockets within the digestive system
now why would people not digest stuff
well enough because or absorb stuff well
enough gluten alert gluten alert gluten
alert gluten alert
yeah and then if the digestive juices
aren't right and breaking stuff down
and glue our buckwheat are both oh my
gosh
but I'm eating healthy you're dead
all right Dr Wallach let's go to the
next town that is up and can't go ahead
and unmute yourself
hi Dr Wallach
um
um first of all four years ago
um the stuff you had given as far as
sweet ease and some things
um I went from a 12.3 A1 ALC to a 6.4 in
less than two months well thank you for
sharing that congratulations and have
kept that at least that away however I
was over a friend's house this was
recent as like a few this um in fact
this week and I fell asleep on my right
arm
and the person I was near a space heater
because the person's house didn't have a
lot of heat and it got real sore and
when I woke up I almost couldn't lift my
right arm and it's coming back gradually
but to me I want things like instant and
today I'm getting ready to go to
University of Penn the doctor to have
him look at it because I'm it seems like
I'm with a shoulder was really aching
it's it's helped is I'm having trouble
lifting it stop
well before you go to the place where
the guy's going to do shoulder surgery
I'd go to Oh no you're not so cutting on
me no yes
we'll start out of the chiropractor okay
okay sorry so cancel that appointment go
to a chiropractor and you know you're
still taking the nutrients correct yes
okay good well how about ramp up and add
if you don't have it in there you want
to throw in the MSM
three of those breakfast lunches that'll
be two bottles a month I would also
throw in the ultimate daily classic
tablets for circulation three of those
twice say those two bottles a month for
circulation
and um I would also throw in the
collagen peptides at school without
their morning drinks with your evening
drink don't forget vitamin D3 take
through those twice a day even if you
live in some Sunny Pacific island
because most people who are adults will
sit in the shade on sunny days on these
Pacific Islands they don't lay out in
the sun in their bikinis like kids do
okay
so make sure you're taking all the
nutrients make serious anyway from all
the bad stuff and I would go to a
chiropractor first you may you know have
somebody you just goes it's 15 20
seconds
yeah
okay thank you you bet
all right Ken thank you so much for
coming on and yeah Chiropractics
chiropractors are amazing Dr Wallach
because they look at the whole
mechanical system of the body
and see where there are weaknesses or
things that are being impinged and then
work on adjusting and releasing those
things that are being inhibited and
keeping the body from being able to move
and function
and so Miriam has a question and I don't
know if her hand is up for the same
question Miriam go ahead and unmute
yourself
no
go ahead my dear okay
um so I heard you Dr Wallach mentioned
earlier an inversion table
um has a helpful tool for someone with
scoliosis my question is would an
inversion table also be helpful for
someone that is trying to correct
um
increase their height and correct
herniated discs along with the healthy
Bone and Joint pack of course very good
yeah anything to do with the mechanics
and physical structure
will be benefited by an inversion table
and the 90 essential nutrients okay
excellent thank you you're very welcome
just be sure to stay away from the bad
stuff
no fried foods no process means no oils
no glutens no buckwheat okay none of
that bad stuff no carbon or drinks no
sugar and you'll maximize the benefit
great thank you so much you bet thank
you let us know how things go okay every
couple weeks
thank you
all right thank you
thank you and folks you are listening to
our stock live and watching ass talk
live here and this is a resource to
provide information that is empowering
that you can do yourself you do not have
to rely on somebody with a piece of
paper to write out what you're supposed
to be doing to take it to uh store to
have it filled
and then have to deal with the side
effects later of
what was prescribed so Dr well like that
is something that I am
super thankful for because all of those
things that I was being prescribed were
not benefiting me and making me sicker
and sicker
and you were alert enough to understand
that so that sounds very good so yeah
when people get introduced to
two facts number one
there's no Professional Health caregiver
that knows everything even I don't know
everything only God knows everything
right and so number two
um
the medical system
they know very little to nothing about
nutrition each or four food groups
that's their system eat the four food
groups
all right you gotta be kidding me that's
all they know about nutrition eat the
four food groups
so that's why they flourish
well and the quantities from those four
food groups in my lifetime on what's
supposed to be
you know it's like that triangle it went
from having good dairies and and
proteins first and meats and then they
flipped it upside down to the whole
grains and that's where
during the time period that I was
grinding my own wheat making my own
flowers you know grind not just wheat
but also the buckwheat and one thing I
wanted to add about the buckwheat so
those Pyro
tell me that word pyro Bagel here with
an fago parents they go Pyrenees Bagel
Pirates when I did some research
um it really made sense with the way
that it causes
extreme irritation to the skin Dr
Welling because it is a chemical within
the grain within the plant that is toxic
and burns well that's why people get
lupus when they eat buckwheat
because it not only affects the
intestines but also affects the skin and
lupus you know your skin and your face
and your arms your neck and your chest
all get I mean like fiery red and
itching and burning and plus you have
only intestinal stuff that is
phagopirings
yeah so it and it's been touted as being
a great gluten-free alternative where
yes it is gluten free but when you've
got this other chemical in there that is
and burning it's just as bad if not
worse so yeah we need to definitely do
research and not just the first things
that come up when we do what are the
benefits of or what's but why not why
not have buckwheat pancakes for
breakfast
and then have uh wheat butter and oat
bread and spaghetti for lunch and dinner
well I mean a whole grains Dr Wallach
that's what we've been told are healthy
for us
so yeah doctors are the one that jumped
on that one right at the turn of the
20th century when everybody began to
gain weight and became obese oh you're
eating too much you're eating too many
fats stop eating animal fat and eat more
whole grains and that just pushed us
over the edge
yeah let's ah goodness those fats have
things that are beneficial for us doctor
well like but Ruth Ellen has a question
for you Dr Wallach
hi I just had a comment about the
buckwheat um when I was looking it up
they had a story about how it is
phototoxic and that they don't give it
to light colored horses because
literally it's on they have sunburns
like if they have a brown horde they had
a picture of a horse that was brown with
a white diamond on his nose all around
the outside of the diamond and in the
center were blisters from the Sun from
eating buckwheat so it's just bad all
the way around
no that's very good there's good
information thank you you're welcome
thank you very much Ruth Ellen and since
we're talking about
photosynthesis and everything we get
vitamin D from the Sun Dr warlick right
yep
well amid has
a question and wants to know what is the
dose dosage of vitamin D that you
recommend
well
I like
um what three times the minimum daily
requirement for humans which is what a
couple hundred
um I use per day
yeah I don't
I don't have my vitamin D here so I
don't know exactly what they're saying
is the RDA
um which I've heard many different
um explanations you're going to hear
many many different ones and you can
Bank on it that we have the upper middle
we're not at the low end
so he says he's taken uh 4 000 IUS of D3
and K2 every day
so
well that was going to be my question Dr
Wallach because I know two of our
vitamin D's have 5 000 IUS or one sorry
five thousand IUS
per tablet hey
but the one thing that I want to point
out is we want to make sure that you're
not just taking vitamin D3 and K2 you've
got to get that foundation in there
hey Siri
so what is the recommended daily dose
for vitamin D3
NHS
if you choose to take Vitamin D
supplements 10 micrograms a day will be
enough for most people do not take more
than 100 micrograms four thousand IU of
vitamin D a day is it could be harmful
this applies to adults including
pregnant and breastfeeding women and the
elderly and children aged 11 to 17 years
there you go
that's low
yes it's low but at least it's a place
to start
yeah I would go 3 900 milligrams my
program security micrograms 3 900
micrograms
when they said four thousand is too much
okay so 4 000 IUS
okay so if if we were to do
three thousand nine hundred
okay
which is lower than I don't I know
there's there's 600 IU
to 15 micrograms
so that's kind of the inversion of the
two so if we're talking
they said 10 micrograms
that's they say like 500 items yeah 10
to 100.
yeah
well I personally and Heather just
brought it up also I like our Citra D
spray Dr Wallach because with the Citra
D spray you do six little sprays under
your tongue and you're getting six
thousand IUS with each yummy tasting
dose there you go see we only have 5 000
products I only use
499 so I apologize
for not knowing everything you've got to
be proud of the top of my head
well Dr Wallach you know everything else
but there Heather is she is holding up
the Citra D
um convenient little spray bottle what
is that is that two ounces or four
ounces Heather
the two ounces and it tastes so good
I mean very yummy very yummy it and
citrusy so vitamin C absolutely
um and then
somebody says not to go oh she's been
told not to go over 50 000 IUS per week
of vitamin D who told her that some
Doctor Who's an orthopedic surgeon
well that's that's possible but
yeah
well anyways Dr Wallach we are coming up
to the end of our program we only have
about seven more minutes left and I did
have a question from somebody called
um through email which I love it when
we're able to get to these emails and
the wife has experienced a stroke Dr
Wallach she's 43 years old
um she's 128 pounds
she has never had high blood pressure no
um diagnoses of blood sugar issues
and she thought she was absolutely
healthy with no problems until she had a
stroke
after going on a hike with her husband
okay well there's two factors one taking
all the right stuff at the right dosages
and then the other factor is absorbing
it
what was the other Factor
the other Factor absorption
absorption you're a little far away from
the microphone I couldn't hear you
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
gluten alert so uh even if she's not
eating gluten but her husband is and
they're washing their clothes together
she's getting crossed contaminated
sleeping with them washing her clothes
with his clothes sitting on the couch
together all that kind of stuff and so
um getting rid of all the bad stuff is
equally important is taking all the good
stuff
so that sounds like that sounds like an
absorption problem to me
person hasn't they've they're requesting
information in regards to what should
they be taking
what would be your full protocol okay
her Strokers they both should be doing
the same thing none of the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no Wheaton about Ryan oats no
sugar no carbon or drinks she needs uh
and the husband can do the same thing
two healthy brain and heart factual
month of photos only twice a day they
need to be taking two bottles a month of
the MSM so they take three breakfast
straight line Street dinner time they
need to be taking the collagen peptides
a scoop of that with breakfast and
dinner vitamin D three three of those
twice a day and then uh the ultimate
daily classic tablets ultimate daily
classic tablets three of those twice
today that's two bottles a month take
three breakfast for dinner that'll
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries and supported healthy
blood pressure
and if there is any blood sugar problems
you know they fall asleep an hour after
eating dinner kind of thing
um or you know just anytime during the
day after lunch fall asleep you'd take a
nap that kind of stuff then they need
the sweeties take three of those fights
today
um it'll be two bottles a month and then
do a hair analysis get the book rare
earth spin cures go to chapter 10 11
page 272 tells you how to collect the
hair how to package it where to ship it
don't forget to put the check in there
because the lab won't run the test
without the check
and then call us when you get the
results back and we'll walk you through
it yeah it's one of those things where
there you go
um that book was written to deal with
our discovery of one disease and all the
things we had to do all the stuff we did
legally in coach and all the stuff we
did in the on the uh autopsy table
everything over a 20-year period to
solve the problem of one disease Rare
Earth being cures okay
all right Dr Wallach and I I love this
book and I have right there marked where
it is that I go to get that information
or the hair analysis and it is on page
274. so make sure that you get that and
and it's not just about getting the
information about how to get your hair
analysis and what Dr recommends as far
as the connect company
um to process a hair analysis but this
book goes through all the things that
are reported on that hair analysis where
they should be as far as
the the levels
and the ratios and how to read your hair
analysis so this book is is more than
just to get an address folks
and you can go to our website
askdoclive.com click on Dr wallach's
books you will find some of his most
popular books and if you don't find what
you're looking for there go to drj
wallick.com and there you will find all
of Dr wallach's Publications so
he and Dr Milan have put together
Wellness Publications
and just a wealth of information of what
you can do on your own as an empowered
individual
okay don't let anybody take your power
away from you be empowered accept the
fact that you are your own authority
when it comes to what you put in your
mouth and in your environment and we do
definitely promote a low toxic and I say
low toxic because it is very difficult
to get non-toxic
I mean even the chemicals that are used
in my blinds here are emitting a little
bit of toxicity even if it's just minute
but there's so much that we can do to
help protect ourselves
and promote healthy living
in anything that we do especially when
it comes to our nutrition
now if I could get one of the co-hosts
just to start adding all of our co-hosts
here to this screen because on behalf of
the ass doc Live Crew
we just want to say thank you or
taking the time
to in and investing the time into
gaining information
about what you can do
I agree team what a great team yes we
have a great team we have Dr Judy
Reynolds we have Heather Bowen we have
Russell and Sanchez we have nasima Omar
I mean
how long have you been with youngevity
12 years
12 years Ruth Ellen was at seven years
I know you've been here just a little
bit longer than I have yes since
February of 2015.
so yeah so just a little bit longer than
me and
we're still here folks
the information that we learned from Dr
Wallach we implemented in our lives and
because of the improvements that we
received
we are standing here together making
sure that more and more people around
the world not just in our backyard but
around the world are hearing the
information
that is life-changing
it changed my life
so and I know with Dr Judy has an
amazing story that we're going to share
some time Heather has an amazing story
that we're going to share some time and
it doesn't matter what age you are if
you are still breathing oxygen
then nutrition is going to be beneficial
within your body
so Dr Wallach thank you once again for
being on with us for the last two hours
we appreciate you all the work that you
have done and myself Rebecca Dukes Kozak
on behalf of the ass doc Live Crew
sponsored by the zbs radio network we
thank you for being on with us and just
hope that you're a sponge observing this
information so that you can wring it out
and share with others get back with the
person that shared this information with
you that share this program with you and
tell them thank you
thank you for helping me find
alternatives
to things that could otherwise be
causing greater harm within the body
have a great one and until next time bye
for now bye bye everybody love you all
thank you so much great job ladies
bye-bye thank you